what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
brooklyn nine-nine what is it john it's
episode 18 it's called cheddar
i believe this guy did not specify
season three season three oh my god you
guys you could be syncing up with like a
season six episode right now you are all
about making sure you're stating
everything
thoroughly
clearly
never assuming the audience could
possibly know and you missed season
three i know you missed season three no
i deserve every bit of this and more
let me talk about
what went wrong when you were a child
let me talk about season one of your
life
all right guys if you could leave a like
i know you can do it also uh full length
reaction watching alongs where you sing
about the time code for ben nine over
for super sexy red jack shadow petra and
uh prepper team thank you for helping us
out he's down let's get to it
this envelope contains the inheritance
my uncle left me he died a year ago he
was so rich he had a whole room in his
house just to eat him you mean like a
dining room yeah but in manhattan oh
dang that is rich i want a ducati
monster 8 21. all right rosa gets a
motorcycle oh cool i want a fast sports
car come on you could be honest i want
old expensive books i'll send you a list
there you go
one million shares oh my god love
blockbuster video stuff yes oh
dad
i still have a blockbuster card
what happened to blockbuster
there had to be at least that one in us
alaska when this aired right yeah
collect definitely have a million
dollars worth in that alaskan collective
one charles the surgery is going to go
fine all right you'll have some vision
impairment for a few hours and i'm gonna
be with you the whole time plus they're
gonna give you some of those sweet-ass
robo-cop sunglasses those are blind
people's sunglasses but they're so cool
fun to play with i'm not going chatter's
regular dog sitter is ill and the heat's
out in my house so i don't think it's a
good time for me to visit kevin in paris
sir what is going on i'm told that blind
people have a special connection with
dogs i knew it you do think i'm gonna go
blind it's an interesting offer but i
don't want to be in a position in
position
sure
probably like a level five not a level i
thought you'd be psyched i mean a week
at captain holt's house wasn't that
where you wanted to spend your honeymoon
yeah but this is too much pressure
[Laughter]
and i was just thinking if that was me
and you it would make me really sad plus
there's this big fat binder full of
instructions and rules there's a binder
[Laughter]
you idiot
i'm gonna just leave you two alone okay
isn't she allergic
what's up what's up with you
i need you to sign this report okay
i'll sign your report
[Laughter]
careful
the ink's still wet maybe this will help
[Applause]
cheddar let go
amy this is a cashmere
sweater oh my stupid allergies we got
into kevin's closet grabbing by the nape
nice job boyle it worked but the mess
jake the mess don't worry we're gonna
clean it up everything is totally under
control charles his pants are on fire
boy out the space heater get away i
think this had to be a reason they put
that there
okay
it's okay everything's fine fire's out
and this table oh
fragile i was gonna say fragile nailed
it
you punching holes that's way too much
paper
not for me
can't even get a cup of coffee
[Laughter]
all right diaz that's it
what's going on with you two oh you
noticed it
everyone's noticed it a convicted
pervert asked me if you guys could cool
it i don't know what to tell you
something between us sarge
something dark and urgent
news the smell of burnt sweat pants and
singed-legged hair has finally
disappeared i just hope i can grow it
back by speedo season
yeah you got this bruh the house might
say jake's a liar and i'm on fire the
security company called me about the
alarm okay the house was never on fire
charles was on fire
i'm coming home right now wait no sir
please don't do that you have to go see
kevin everything's fine no my decision
is final i'm postponing my flight
goodbye jacob no sir please please
call him jacob
he can't come home we left the door open
and the dog ran out what we lost cheddar
these silences are very hard for me to
read what's the vibe in here we're
freaking out charles
good afternoon thank you all for joining
oh no
our man has been on the run for 30
minutes also now i know what some of you
are thinking who cares it's just a pet
no one was thinking that you monster
good that was a test
hour which means with every passing
second
that slippery bastard gets farther away
she's gonna wreck your car here's where
we're at amy and i will take blind
charles and search the neighborhood diaz
pimento bring the dog back dead or alive
[Laughter]
watch me now
no gina the wrong way no gina the spikes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh not a problem i can get you i'm on
two wheels
uh yeah
and bearing tires
i'm gonna stop messing around and do
this thing never what you know what i
just realized i i forgot something at
home i'm just gonna no
no promento sorry but you'd only slow us
down that's exactly what cheddar wants
i'm on to you you slippery little
bastard
[Laughter]
i got nothing did you find cheddar close
shredder no
no shredder
charles is a grown man he can take care
of himself no he's not he's a charles
all right and he's blind oh god he's
probably already dead right so let's not
waste any resources on him
i'll move i know exactly where you are
he's at the entrance by seventh street i
used to hang out there all the time
i've boofed it nothing
she was a bartender at the garbage box
second-rate strip club my mob buddies
that i used to go to but i couldn't save
her from the pole hmm boss impaled her
on a pole when he caught her skimming
tips
[Laughter]
after what i've seen
after what i've done
i don't know that i deserve to be happy
of course you do
i never looked at it that way
that changes everything
i never even finished my point no
sarge you said it all
you just changed my life
oh my
he referred you by name hey there's
charles jake jake charles we're behind
you oh look
i found you
i know pretty impressive right wow it
was a proud day for blind people
everywhere
charles it wasn't easy though this guy
put up quite a fight oh no we're good
friends now right
right you gave me a bunch of kisses
[Music]
no no no no
can we please drop the charade so i can
get home already absolutely sir wait i
should tell you
before you got real with me i did rip
out all these wires
you guys go off the grid i'm listening
go on i get you guys mexican passports
totally untraceable we fake your death
in an apartment fire i'll need three
teeth from both
amazingly wearing holt's clothes is our
best option
everyone
prepare to enter high society
[Music]
[Laughter]
how's everybody feeling anyone else have
the weird urge to lecture themselves
peralta what are you doing
peralta what are you doing oh no
why is the whole squad here why is
everyone wearing my clothes you lost
cheddar
how did you do that
uh
i'm sorry that i got you involved in
this i never should have volunteered us
no jake it's not your fault
it's amy's what well it's not my fault
blind
exactly and that's why i think it's
kevin's fault i have an idea of how to
find cheddar don't act weird when i say
this but we're gonna need to use the
binder oh mama
can we talk
what do you want pimento listen
sarge gave me some really great advice
so
rosa
this is what you told me to do i barely
said anything you cut me off way too
early sarge stay out of this no i will
not marry you
how about we just get a drink first yeah
that sounds nice oh that's actually
sweet
[Laughter]
i think we know where cheddar is will
you please just get in the car
nope let me get that try now
colossal can't control the locks hang on
try now just hold it open
better try now here we come cheddar try
now right now right now here we come
cheddar try now
i mean you and kevin are the best couple
i know i'm sure whatever this is you can
get through it because you are the
strongest person i know i felt weird but
good are you proud of me you're ruining
it yep
[Laughter]
it's a miracle i can see not now charles
right i'm sorry
[Laughter]
all right john i got seven minutes take
it away all right any episode with
adrian pimento is a good episode it was
a lot of fun very heartwarming i liked
the surprisingly touching ending what
did you think
uh yeah that was really funny that was
really uh man that jason
mandzukic regular now
it seemed i mean at least a recurring
regular until they maybe wrap up his
plotline but i sure hope he's just a
series regular i don't know
i don't know i mean
even in i like the i like the ending a
lot with holt it was really touching
especially when he was
you know revealing that him and kevin
were having problems and that he was
really just finding excuses to avoid
seeing him as of the fear that they
might end due to that but you know
sometimes we have that much distance it
can create arguments when really what's
happening is you're missing each other
so
yeah i mean i feel like it's just basic
what's going on with them just go go and
see each other
but if i was holes i'd be pissed i would
not have just forgiven so easily even if
we found the dog i'd be uh very very
furious yeah fire in my house let the
dog out
clothes ruined destroyed table
wearing my clothes
i'd be pissed
i would never let it fly
two weeks i'd hold a grudge
i got a two week hold is what i would do
two week grudge two-week grudge
but yeah it was funny this is a funny
one a lot of cutaways i do have some
qualms about amy lately though oh what
are they
it's
like because women aren't funny
no not just that okay okay
mainly that yeah it's hard to get around
that
yeah
it's like
there are already so many women you have
to put up with trying to be funny on the
show
you know you got three at least at least
three ways like 300 percent more women
than i'm used to
[Laughter]
no uh
how do i liken it sometimes in sitcoms
it's usually like way later in a series
though when they started doing this
i saw it happen with dwight
on office
it's like definitely happening with the
monika in friends
where it was like i get it you're ocd
and you like things clean and that's
your you keep going back to that joke
and that's kind of the it's like it's so
hyper quirky this one joke and it's like
doesn't really get that much funnier
it's just kind of a button you push and
they keep relying on it with amy as like
yeah that's her she's she's quirky
because she's she's a book nerd
nerd [ __ ] yeah yeah and uh
like i don't know just it's just getting
it's getting old fast and usually that's
like a season six thing to do yeah like
we're out of [ __ ] to do for her
so we're gonna really hone in on this
we're not doing as much character
development anymore so we just got to
give everybody a thing yeah yeah and uh
that is kind of the quirk with amy that
i don't know she kind of felt more like
it's been kind of missing for me this
season and it's been kind of hit or miss
because i feel like before she was like
a real character and easily one of like
my top two like her holt and uh peralta
were like my top three and i'm like oh
you know what she's actually
she doesn't she's just kind of
way way weavers in and out now for me as
like sometimes she's feels like a real
character
and a lot of times she's like a
quirky comedy character now
and so
yeah
yeah i feel like i don't really know if
i've communicated that clearly or rather
that just sounds weird no that makes it
i mean that makes perfect sense to me
and i can see that like like especially
in the
lead up to her and jake getting together
i feel like there was a good amount of
yeah oh character bits and we're
actually seeing from her perspective and
since then there hasn't been as much of
that and it has been more
you know amy's part of the comedy
ensemble
than like a real focused character who
gets you know development and who gets
like vulnerable moments a lot usually
it's the same moments or circa jake it's
just that same joke all over and over
again and it's like you can see it
coming all the time yeah yeah yeah
anything sort of dry and bookly like oh
she's trying to pretend that she's not
this but she really is this yeah i'm
like having someone think of this joke
so um yeah
i would do that with true like i see it
happen all the time in comedy sitcoms
that's what i'm getting at so i'm like
just happening a little earlier than i
expected it to uh and like i could see
them like writing off gina early on
like i can imagine gina leaving the show
before
like just knowing how sitcoms go i feel
like gina is probably the kind of
character who would leave
before the show actually ends and then
we get a new quirky receptionist yeah by
a different comedic actor
yeah
but i like the chemistry a lot with rosa
and jason especially because there was
so much teasing of like her wanting to
bang him so then the fact that they
actually paired them up this time yeah
oh my god they work well they work
really well off each other i know and
like the way they read each other and
playing to that bit was just freaking
hilarious oh so much fun to watch
together i got the nipple chills this
episode
why
just the two of their chemistry man oof
that give you nip for chills
[Laughter]
at one point
what the [ __ ]
you know just weird sexual tension
okay good for you
whatever gets you the nipple chills
that's right man don't worry i'll tune
them kills their nipple chills but the
reason for getting them is all
subjective
i'm glad i'm glad you know as the
originator of the the the phenomenon as
it stands here you know i i appreciate
your approval of that
yeah
i also really liked all the dog cutaways
and how they were paced because they
really did feel like they probably just
made one of those videos of a dog going
around town except then they
really cut it down to like slivers of
moments
it really feels like you're watching
some kind of like quirky pbs like oh
let's follow this dog except it's only
like a five second cut away there's an
abundance of cutaways in this episode
this was the cutaway episode yeah a
large abundance like it was like
borderline family guy and then how many
cutaways they did
boy but there's a really funny episode
nice development of the characters
quality app the whole blind bit was
amazing the possum one uh yeah nah
charles the possum was funny i really
like the possible one
it looked like a real possum that was a
real possum i was like wow i guess they
must have
animal trainers who work with possums
for movies and stuff like that
that i wonder what they i wonder what
was going on there because that possum
at the end really did look like he
didn't want to be held anymore yeah and
i was like is this something they
trained
you know is there like a trainer off
camera like doing something or is that
just like a possum who's tired of this
possums are can be sweet actually we
have a lot of pop we get possums in our
backyard oh yeah oh yeah i bet you
should grab one and bring it in
all right guys well that's it for today
what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below and hey let's end
this with a patron
james
smith welcome to the patreon buddy
you've got a cool spelling on your last
name it's like ooh deceptive smith
probably pretty common what there's a y
in the middle of it holy crud
you could be a beat cop but since this
is this is james smith's first shot
first shout out
we got to do the protocol we got to do
by the book all right we're not going
rogue at this precinct greg what does
the jay and james smith stand for it
took a long time to get there i just
wanted this suspension i
is it gonna be the classic or am i gonna
get something i can't not get the
classic and now james is like wrapped
with the tension
and james
chase stands for
just tastic just tastic
jizz-tastic and ace trying to hide it
from youtube
ass tastic because you got that bubble
butt m stands for
my man
yes sir and e stands for every man
should be like james smith s stands for
semen
seven seven james yep
you probably got some [ __ ]
simon james
just testing seven james that's your
news too happy to be here
oh yeah so you know that's for you now
you can tell your people yeah you should
wear that unnamed tag swallow it man
it's good
enjoy it man
please
please please don't leave us after this
first experience we promise to be
respectful
[Music]
you